Let's go to, let's go to Mark from Newport.
We haven't heard from Mark from Newport for
a while. What's going on, Mark.
Right. David, thank you for taking my call.
Um, I wanted to know your opinion. I'm sure
you've seen, I know recently there was the
Pew research study that showed the decline
of religiosity city in the U S and I personally
am worried about some of the resulting societal
consequences, but I wanted to know your thoughts.
Uh, well would, you'd have to tell me what
consequences you're worried about.
Sure. So I guess a couple things. So according
to Pew, the same, uh, group that provided
the first set of numbers is they said, for
example, religious people are overall happier.
They're overall have better health outcomes.
There was an Ohio state university study that
said controlling for socioeconomic status
and race and income and age, that religious
people live longer. Uh, university of Indiana
said religious folks give more to charity,
which is true, again, controlling for all
of those factors. Excuse me. The Harvard medical
school said that religious people suffer significantly
less mental health problems. But I guess to
be clear, I am not saying that the only way
we can improve those categories is her religion.
I'm saying that the decline in religion is
pulling the rug out from so much and I don't
think we'll be able to pick up the pieces
as fast as they're falling, if I phrase that.
Okay.
Why do you think that the States that have
a lower percentage of folks that are religious
seem to be a better off economically in terms
of education, in terms of health outcomes,
in terms of mental health? Why, why do you
think that is?
Hmm. Well, I think looking between States
is actually not controlling for enough variables
because you're not accounting for like the
state level and governance. So what I, what
I think controls like best isolates the variable
of religiosity is looking within specific
States where you're, you're holding constant,
um, you know, governance, history, that sort
of thing.
That's fair.
Specific States which holds more, um, variables,
con constant. Um, in every metric I just gave
religious people turn out better.
Yeah. I've just not seen that data. Everything
I'm looking at has, it has at minimum failed
to demonstrate that it is because of religion
that some of these differences exist. But
I've, I've not even seen the data you're citing
so I would have to look into it. But, you
know, a big, big picture, I'm not worried
about it. And, uh, I, you know, when, when
we look at, um, countries that are less religious
as well, you know, you could make the same
argument, which is, well, the countries that
are less religious might for other reasons
be doing, be, um, have happier people so to
speak or whatever the case may be. Uh, but
I've just not seen the data that you're citing.
So I'd like to look at it.
Sure. Um, like I, I think that what you just
said is very interesting too. Like for example,
um, like, like I think the obvious example
is Western Europe where religiosity is far
lower than Eastern Europe and Western Europe
is much happier. But then, you know, I, I
don't think comparing like, um, England for
example, to, uh, a, the former member of the
Soviet block is a great comparison, but looking
in a lot of these countries, so like for example,
this is like what the Pew, the Pew data demonstrates
when they look at religious folks within specific
countries are holding variables constant that
within any or most countries, um, religious
folks are happier.
Yeah. That was not my takeaway from the Pew
study, but it has been a little while since
I looked at it. So I'll, I'll review the data
Mark, but a very interesting question that
you're bringing up.
Yeah. This is like, I think the fifth time
you've accepted my call. So thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
All right, Mark. Very good to hear from you.
Thank you so much. And I'm sure we will be
hearing from him again. Let's go next to our
caller from the nine, seven, three area code.
Who's calling today from nine 73.
Dave sent me.
Yes it is.
Huh?
All right. So I was just kinda curious why
you don't hear a lot of left-wing positions
being argued from a right wing perspective.
And uh, my example, and this would be something
like climate change where we typically focus
on things like the science and stuff that
often gets put up for debate in mainstream
media, but you never hear some like, um, a
lot of our national enemies like, uh, Russia,
Iran or Venezuela, their condoms are very
heavily dependent on hydrocarbons. So the
best way to attack them would be to take out
their canopies. So you never hear things like
that and just kind of wondering why
there's actually a big debate about this,
um, about whether it makes sense to argue
for our policy based on arguments that would
be appealing to the other side. And it's,
it's not clear to me that it's a good idea.
I've read really good, uh, arguments on both
sides. One being yes, we should, even if there
are arguments in favor of a policy we want
that don't match up with our priorities, if
it's going to influence someone else, we should
still make those arguments. Um, but then there
are lots of other folks, like for example,
Nathan J. Robinson who I interviewed who said
he, he said he thinks it's a bad idea that
he should be arguing for the policies we believe
are the right ones for the reasons we believe
that they are the right ones. So I think first
we have to, when you're asking why don't we
hear it more? First we have to figure out
whether it's a good idea and it seems to be
an open question at this point. At least on
many issues.
Okay, good. Yeah. Do you mind if I ask one
more
bumped by? Go ahead.
So as long as in a wondering what the impact
the weather might be on the upcoming democratic
primary with the El Nino coming up for 2020
whether or not more increment, colder weather,
it could potentially impact candidates who
have less voter enthusiasm. So if someone
like Joe Biden and Mikey hurt more than someone
like Bernie,
well adapt it. It's certainly conceivable,
but I would, uh, we can't control that. And
either way, if that's going to be a factor,
it's going to be a factor. I don't think it's
one of the, it's fine to speculate, but I
don't think it's very actionable one way or
the other.
Okay, great. Thank you very much.
All right, appreciate the phone call. Thank
you.